[Music]
i honestly like part of me really um was
in display because
i'm like okay why would law enforcement
be watching me i'm not doing anything
wrong i knew that something wasn't right
if i was driving away from work or
whatever there was always car or cars
following me and it's just it just felt
weird
a matter of fact the fun fact when the
first time i seen that
um i actually called the police on one
of them and i told them hey there's this
weird guy taking pictures of me what's
going on the cop they came they pulled
up they pulled they pulled them up they
had their lights on they were talking to
them and um he came up to me he's like
oh no he's just taking pictures of the
signs you know they're doing
advertisement but that's when i realized
he actually showed him the badge and let
him know what was going on you know so
the cop even tried to downplay it like
hey it's just a guy taking pictures of
his sign you know don't worry about it
all right story time my first day of
prison listen if anybody has been to
prison and they tell you they were not
nervous they are absolutely lying
reason being is because you have no idea
what the expectation is when you walk
into the prison so when i went to
federal prison at terre haute indiana we
were actually locked down for a few days
because of an incident
so when i got to the cell unit you can
see trash and things like that
everywhere because they were locked down
for a few days
now i am muslim at the federal prison i
was at it was separated by race and
geographical location
when they put me in that cell it was
actually a white cell which is a no-go
me as a muslim cannot sell with a white
guy
so he basically told me what are you
what time you're on i basically told hey
i'm muslim i'm rolling with the muslim
you say hey man look no disrespect this
is just how the prison operates we
cannot i cannot have you in my cell
so him and i basically talked to
lieutenant and the counselor there
they're able to find me to a different
cell a muslim cell i got out of prison
uh december 2019 out to check into a
halfway house but i got out of custody
june of 2020.
and so that's obviously like right
before the pandemic started
just about right before it when it was
it was yeah pretty much starting
[Music]
i joined tick tock i believe about four
or five months after i was officially
off federal custody
i don't know if it's just me because i
just got out of prison but how weird is
it to walk into a bank with a mask on
i'm about to walk in there right now
you know honestly i really did feel like
it was like a kids app i was hearing
about tick tock when i came out but when
i seen it i was completely wrong i was
scrolling through and i've seen people
making videos about they're doing their
time in prison i said hey you know what
i might give it a try as well
i was going through basically a real
tough time with depression i started to
post a video on tick tock where you can
use a sound you can post random pictures
and videos i put videos of my mug shot
me in court and then me transitioning
back to society about being with family
and things like that and then it just
absolutely blew up and i said hey man
this actually works some people do time
and never talk about it but for me when
i clicked that record button and i
posted a video about my time in prison
talking about it was actually making me
feel better about my situation
that one reached about a half a million
my first video
can you listen to music in prison the
answer is yes can you wear hats in
prison yes can you eat chips in prison
absolutely did we have clean water in
prison the answer is no what was prison
like one word pain
so do i feel like my religion played a
part into my sentencing yes absolutely i
really wholeheartedly believe that there
are some racism and prejudice in our
criminal justice system when you go to
purchase a firearm you fill out a form
and on that form i lied saying that i
was not using drugs when actuality i was
using drugs and was your sentencing uh
unusual
uh yes it went about 40 months over the
actual guidelines i was supposed to get
10 or 15 months that's anybody with a
gun case
[Music]
so i grew up in a middle eastern
household
my parents split up about when i was
three or four years old primarily i was
raised by my uh
dad's side of the family so but other
than that i mean it was like pretty much
you know they
caring and loving
dearborn is predominantly an arab uh
city so it's kind of like a little
middle east within
you know uh america
when you live kind of like in the middle
eastern cuba household they try to like
shelter you as much as possible
[Music]
i was pretty much dealing with mental
health my whole life as far as
depression
after high school that's where things
kind of you know kind of went downhill
as far as mental health because now i'm
not in school anymore it's just me
i was working at the pizzeria i did a
big mistake as far as not go to school
right away i decided to take a break
at least i had kind of had people i
could hang around with in school and
make people laugh with friends
[Music]
but they were all gone
i got into drugs
uh these are slices we kind of
cook the slices ready to order
weighing by like three ounces three and
a half ounces
so when we make the slice it comes out
like a little small personal pizza
rather than like a
you know like a regular slice type of
thing you know
working in detroit as a pizza driver is
probably one of the most dangerous jobs
you can have
you go to apartments you go late nights
i mean there's blocks with no porch
lights
your honor i work in my dad's pizzeria
in the city of detroit
your honor of the eight years we have
been open
i have been robbed at gunpoint
i have been jumped and robbed on
deliveries
there were times i pulled up to an
abandoned house and then i ended up
getting robbed
as you know your honor
being a pizza delivery guy is a matter
of life and death
that's when i bought and registered a
firearm
so
uh
when when did you first start viewing
like extremist material online
[Music]
for me it was just a matter of like
shocking off
why would somebody want to watch an
action movie
it's one thing to watch an action movie
but it's another thing to like see stuff
and it's actually like real life
you know just to kind of get that
exhilarating thing just to pass the time
you
i mean i have the know where they you
know they burned that pilot i have a
bunch of pictures and videos of you know
stuff
[Music]
i was getting repeated dms from this
person and this person portrayed
themselves to be a soldier
or a fighter of
isis and they said that hey we're
looking for
people to do coordinate attacks at these
particular locations i ignored him
ignoring mike nordem i mean one day he
just blew up my dms on twitter
and was basically calling me a coward
called me bunch of names and this then i
returned that favor back started to cuss
him out you know and then he said hey
you know i'm getting ready to take my
this is what he said getting ready to
take myself over there and uh getting
ready to die and this that in the third
and him and i was just going kind of
back and forth you know but like for me
it was obvious whatsoever i knew it
clicked that something didn't seem right
with this it just was not right at all
[Music]
all right so one day i was leaving work
normal day i was getting out as i pull
out from work not even 10 15 feet later
i see two cop cars pulling me over i
thought that was weird i just got out of
work nothing happened anyway as i'm
driving i see the cop cars with their
lights on i hurry up and pull over to
this intersection right here as i pull
over the cops immediately had their
weapons drawn telling me to get out of
the vehicle get out of the vehicle
one cop comes to the door tells me to
get out the car i told him hey man i got
a gun on me i did have a gun they threw
me on the ground they were able to
retrieve the gun
they brought in canine units they
searched the car there they found the
marijuana so i was charged with
possession of a firearm ccw and
possession of marijuana asked why did
you pull me over they said one cop said
you were speeding other cops said i had
these uh prayer beads on my uh
my rear view he said this is why we
stopped it because of the destruction of
vision
the whole stop lasted about maybe three
hours where are they actually searching
the car up and down they brought in the
canine units just absolutely tearing my
car up and they were pretty much posted
for a few hours by the time i actually
got transported to the local jail
i stayed the night and i was able to get
out in the morning the
officer that discharged me said that the
prosecutors are still you know debating
whether they're gonna file charges or
not but about a few week about a month
after a fact they did file another
warrant and they arrested me on another
traffic stop i was getting off work same
thing i'm driving carefully and they
pulled me over and as soon as they
pulled me over told me to step out and
handcuffed me told me i have a warrant
for my arrest so they re-arrested you
for the same thing for the same thing
[Music]
[Music]
so gotta contact she dm me on twitter
and she showed me a few pictures of
herself and the pictures portrayed her
to be a very beautiful girl her posing
at the mirror photos herself and her
family her and her brother she showed me
like random pictures of you know her
brother's graduation her graduation
we decided to uh exchange phone numbers
um and we were just texting non-stop all
day every day did you ever actually talk
to her on the phone no and and so had
you ever had like a girlfriend prior to
no i haven't had a girlfriend i mean i
haven't had as much as you know getting
hugged by a girl or kissed by a girl
um i've had high school crushes but it
was a situation where you know i was
rejected by them so i haven't had any
type of experience with women you know
it just quickly escalated from getting
to know one another to
you know potentially talking about
marriage and i let her know like hey my
faith dictates that i can't play games
with you
so we're talking about our whole future
within that few days to a week
[Music]
it's like hey you know we can't keep
going this behind our family's backs i
think it's both
it's best for each other if we meet each
other's families i told my dad about it
he said well we'll go to ohio no problem
and i told her hey everything's final on
my set everything is good
the next day
she basically said that hey you know i'm
getting second thoughts about this i
don't know about this and i don't know
we should talk anymore and that was it
that's it
never heard from her again maybe i came
off too clingy maybe i was just me i was
rushing the situation
[Music]
i entirely put that blame on myself
a couple weeks after i stopped hearing
from god i got a new message on twitter
from uh jenna
she's basically telling me like hey i
really need to talk to you
i feel like god has connected us to talk
i really need to talk to you
she is a 19 year old iraqi from michigan
who lives with her parents
she said that she wore a full uh abeya
they call it and that's basically a full
veil
her parents are like absolutely
destroying her life
she was suicidal she's tired of life and
she needs somebody to talk to so she
basically was portraying the fact that
she just had it with life
[Music]
[Music]
for me my intention was to get to know
this girl and help her out
i said okay i lost the first one maybe
the second one you know
[Music]
[Music]
i basically was telling her like hey you
know
um
i'm thinking about
i think was it that conversation no it
was like a week beforehand no i'm sorry
yeah it was a situation where i was at
work and i was pretty much tired of work
and i told her pretty much like i don't
know if i can keep doing this anymore
you know and then that's when she called
me so and that was the first time you
had spoken yeah and what was that
conversation like uh i mean
she was basically telling like hey you
know you kind of need to keep going and
you know it's not right for you to
um
you know
it's not right for you to self-harm
yourself you know so if it's a situation
where you want to do something like that
it's supposed to do it in the way of god
i'm like at the phone i'm like man
you're crazy i'm not trying to hurt
anybody i'm just dealing with some
issues right now you know
was that the first time she had brought
up the idea of hurting other people
no no
i mean we exchanged so much messages
random stuff but i think within a second
or third week she started mentioning
that
for me i was like
instead keep brushing it aside side to
side i kept on telling her like you
don't know what you want and you
probably just need to get married
i actually ghosted her and i was like
you know i'm done with this for three
days because the conversation just got
too ridiculous with her on her end for
three days i ignored her and for those
three days she was blowing up my phone
it shifted off from the violent stuff to
now she needs somebody to talk to now
that she misses me just like hey my mom
beat me because i didn't cook the rice
right
[Music]
for me it was a matter of flirting with
her
[Music]
i never had experience with women or
talking with women i was always awkward
and shy around women so for me
those were things that that was turning
her on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when i try to venture off to other
things i see her pulling away you know
i was scared to lose her
it was pretty much random the day i woke
up jenna texted me and asked me that hey
are you going to work i said yeah i'm
going to work saying she's like okay
so just getting ready go to work or go
fill up gas
i go to park over here which is where
you use a parking spot i go over there
to go open the store and as i'm walking
to go open the store i just see one
eight one federal agent come out with
his with a big ar looking type of gun
told me to get on the floor i looked at
him like that and i was completely in
disbelief like what's going on here and
pretty much i knew it i'm surrounded by
a bunch of federal agents with guns in
my face telling me get on the floor get
on the floor and i told them hey you
know this is my name you make sure you
got the right guy they say yeah we got a
warrant for your arrest and i look at
one guy's bulletproof vest and says fbi
i'm like fbi i say it out loud as i'm
thinking the guy tell me yeah we're
actually all fbi and i'm like what in
the world did i do to get in trouble
with the fbi as i'm arrested here they
did also simultaneous raid at my house
they uh cuffed my brother they took my
mom out of the house with my baby sister
so so after you're taken into custody by
the fbi are you ever released after that
or are you just in common no i did not
see the light of day until i got out of
prison
so they take me to the fbi building at
an interrogation room uh they do with
their little formal introductions they
tell me what i was charged for i
initially told them i said lawyer
i said that few times they tried to give
me a paper to sign off my rights i
pushed him back and i said hey at this
time i'd like to speak to an attorney
please that time the conversation was
supposed to been ended
but instead they say well we still have
some more questions and then they kept
on prying and prying and then that's
where they brought up that other stuff
my heart dropped in a sense because i'm
like this is what this is about and then
i repeatedly kept on asking him what am
i being charged with he said firearms so
i'm like why is this even relevant then
if i'm not being charged with this stuff
during the fbi interrogation the fbi
made it seem that jenna is in the second
room next to me in trouble as well
i'm telling them this is a whole
misunderstanding
[Music]
i go to the courthouse to get arraigned
on charges and i sit down with an
attorney an attorney tells me she reads
the complaint and she reads that agenda
was an informant
[Laughter]
i'm like she's an informant
and my laura was like yes she's an
informant and i just it was i literally
put my head down i was like i
it was it was heartbreaking
imagine a relationship ending you're in
a state there's always a stage of denial
you know so yeah it was a weird way to
deny it given the fact that i was in
custody you know not broken up you know
but nah i didn't want to believe it
[Music]
there was no answer at the home of
khalil abu rayon this is a photo of the
22 year old holding up one finger the
fbi claims this demonstrates part of his
alleged support for isis the feds have
been watching abu rayon since last may
the dearborn heights man came under
surveillance after pro isis twitter
posts gun purchases and the online
conversations abu rayon had with someone
he didn't know was an undercover fbi
agent abu rayon told that agent he had
an ak-47 and quote i tried to shoot up a
church one day it's one of the biggest
ones in detroit i had it planned out i
bought a bunch of bullets i practiced
reloading and unloading
my
lawyer todd shanker he gave me this
quote that a grand jury indicts a ham
sandwich meaning whatever charges you
put on a grand jury the grand jury is
going to indict you on it and for them
to return back with no indictment on
terrorism really just goes to show that
the prosecution did not prove beyond
reasonable doubt that there was some
type of crime committed there
calling case number
16-30039 the united states of america
versus khalil abu ryan your honor todd
shanker appearing on behalf of mr ryan
standing to my left
they
took advantage of this young man and
they inserted an undercover agent
everything that came after that was
about khalil
trying to say what he thought she wanted
to hear
and they tried to radicalize him and by
radicalize i don't mean looking at
videos on twitter
i mean going out and hurting somebody
and he never did it
he never did it and the closest thing in
that affidavit
is the paragraph
about him
loading up his car
with and he told the undercover that was
an ak-47 and his dad found it well his
dad has submitted this affidavit that
never happened government executed
search warrants
and did they find an ak-47 no
and what i think is interesting in these
conversations that have been outlined
for the court they left off the
conversation that was had with khalil
the night before the arrest
the undercover brought up the church
shooting again
she said whatever whatever happened to
that
and khalil said
i don't want to hurt anybody
what i want to do
is marry you
and have a family
but just as every other time that he
said that she would say
she she basically said no she said
you're a fraud
her name was jana bride
janna in arabic
means paradise
coincidentally
rayon
in arabic means door to paradise
[Music]
[Music]
my lawyer told me is like hey look you
know we couldn't go to trial but i just
feel like the facts of the case for the
gun charge is probably not in your best
interest
um i feel like you know you should
probably plead guilty
uh because it's going to be very hard to
you know
show that you are innocent when you know
i was already pled guilty to the state
and whereabouts
[Music]
some people just talk straight for like
a minute what i do is i try to take like
little takes you know so i can just
gather my thoughts some people ask me
why are you cutting why are you cutting
because you know i don't like to speak
all just one minute just straight you
know an idea might pop up i might mess
up and if i mess up i can just press the
little uh
delete key right here you know and i
just go from there so do i have any tips
for a co starting out well first and
foremost is how i want you guys to look
at it don't look at yourselves like cops
do more like counselors we understand
that you guys have a job to do however
respect goes a long way if you guys
respect us we'll respect you
for about six months i was in solitary
confinement due to the allegations of my
case they felt like i was too high
profile to be out in general public
i am not the same ever since then i
really do firmly believe that a part of
me actually did break when i was in
there
i felt like i was forgotten i mean i
thought my family forgot about me i
thought that this would this was going
to be my life that i was going to be in
solitary confinement i got into the
fetal position and i broke down it was
it was it was uh destroy destroyed was
it was brutal it was torture
what happens if you cry in prison now
prison is surrounded by men so it is
very a masculine environment one might
think that is very weak to cry however
you are in prison your freedom is taken
away so there are inmates who do cry so
if you go to a federal active yard
groups are separated by thing called
cars you have state cars you have
religious cars and you have gang cars so
if somebody's new when they walk and
they say what car are you in so
basically what time are you on a lot of
people have this idea the food in
federal prison you're gonna get like
steaks and scallops federal prisons are
not like what it used to be don't get me
wrong you do have some good trades but
for the most part it is trash it's
prison prison etiquette that i learned
part six today's lesson we're going to
talk about calling someone the b word so
if you have been following me yes i was
in prison with the somali pirate the one
they made the movie out of he was the
only survivor when they hijacked that
american ship so i have a story time on
this when i got sent to seg over a fight
that i was involved with now some guy
just walks into the tv room and without
asking permission changes the channel my
muslim brother and the guy kind of get
into it words are exchanged they go in
the cell start tussling i see the muslim
guy have to do it in a headlock so i
want to go break it up but what i didn't
know is the guy's finger was attached to
the door so his finger was severed as
soon as i opened it his finger looked
like really like a hot dog the guy goes
to medical and i'm trying to clean up
the whole damn mess it was my sale was
funny part the last six months to your
sentence they call it getting short
basically you're on your way out the
door everybody was getting on my nerve
so what do you wear when you get
released from prison no you're not going
to wear the jumpsuit or the prison
uniform of that institution a lot of
people do is they'll wear their grays
which you can buy off commissary which
is like gray sweatpants or a gray
t-shirt at least the prison i was
incarcerated at about a week or two
before your bit released you can
actually have your family send you in
close as well
last couple days uh i didn't sleep i
couldn't sit still
fun fact actually the day i was supposed
to get out they were supposed to have a
federal execution plan the same day
they had protesters they had news they
had everybody there getting ready for
that execution so they pretty much
locked down that whole area
so a camper had to drop me off at a
local walmart camper just literally
dropped me off there and what do i do in
the middle of indiana you know and i
didn't have a phone obviously and i was
just asking people you know can i use
your phone a few people said no and one
lady actually did say yeah you can use
my phone i called my dad say hey i'm at
the walmart this section
over here
now that i'm out of prison um i have
i've gotten into a relationship where
it's serious now
[Music]
at first yes it was very difficult for
me to actually trust this person i
initially thought for actually for a
while that this person was in fact an
undercover informant history is
repeating itself
so do i feel like the feds are still
watching me i really do think so now i'm
not going to get into how i know for a
fact they're still watching me but i
really know for a fact that it is
happening and that's okay i'm not really
doing anything if they want to raise
their resources go ahead and waste your
resources when this person found out
what the actual facts were you know she
was very understanding that you know hey
i can see why now you had your thoughts
and your your paranoia where it came
from and i'm glad i made the decision to
trust this person more now it's a
serious uh relationship now
so
[Music]
it's just like like this was like the
worst basically like it was a real
relationship to you with both these
women yeah and it was fake to them but
it was real to you and now like your
your like worst relationship is just
like available for anyone to like parse
like you read the transcripts transcript
like have you gone back and read those
transcripts or listen to the audio yeah
i mean i i have not necessarily listened
to the auto but i have read the
transcripts some of the conversations
we've had the things that i've you know
uh said um and i i mean i just can't
believe that i was like i said it was
like a real relation to me i firmly
believe that these women were actual
women who were actually interested in me
[Music]
the fbi knew exactly what i was missing
in my life and that was a girl
hello
hello
where is your parents
she just stepped out to groggers
but she's gonna be like any minute um
[Music]
what's wrong
why do you say you want to hang yourself
today did you say you want to kill
yourself today
why
you're just saying that right like you
didn't plan anything
[Music]
i mean it's not that hard it's hard to
take your own life
[Music]
[Music]
how do you want to do it like what do
you mean
like you just tied the rope
and
[Music]
right you don't have no rope or nothing
you have a rope
where'd you get your rope from
there's a dollar store you know it's
easy to get one
you know it's not the problem of getting
rope is just you gotta do it
we want and then your family and then
you have your your little sister
[Music]
but you you won't do it in your house
[Music]
no that's not please get that that out
of your
[Music]
nobody should take away their own lives
habib we know nobody should take away
their own lives
it's haram it's not it's not something
that we should be thinking about allah
gives us
trials
problems but
we have to be strong enough to tackle
these problems you know nothing stays
the same
i mean
like i told you before you know when
it's
subhanallah this making me really sad or
when it's
for the sake of allah when it's
jihad or when it's based on our akhida
or for a cause that's the only time
allah subhana wa tahalah allows it but
not
to put your life to waste and
and just
hang yourself like you say you want to
do that's not the right thing to do
[Music]
but i mean i'm feeling a little better
than i'm talking to you
you promised it you're not going to do
anything to hurt yourself
i promise you i promise you okay good
and thank you for trusting me and
calling me
to help you with this thank you all
right
[Music]
okay smile don't be sad
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
you